if you applied a coat of paint to the
bottom of your shoes every single day
one coat on top of the other every
morning you would leave Earth just as
quickly as our moon is leaving us
every day the moon moves about a tenth
of a millimeter away from Earth it's 3.8
centimeters further away from us every
year that's about the length of an air
pod the Moon is leaving us because the
world is turning the moon's gravity
causes the Earth to slightly bulge but
because the Earth rotates in the same
direction as the moon's orbit the Bulge
tugs on the moon speeding it up and the
faster something moves tangentially to a
gravitational pull the more successfully
it escapes that gravity and the further
out it orbits the moons equal an
opposite pull on the Bulge slows down
Earth's rotation and if the Earth and
Moon survive the death of our sun 5
billion years from now 45 billion years
after that they will be tidally locked
to each other for half of the Earth the
moon will appear permanently fixed to a
point in the sky and the other half will
never see the moon again
thank you